hey this is Prestel Walker reminding you
to mind your decisions a gigantic pie is
split amongst 100 guests the first guest
gets one percent of the pie then the
second guest gets two percent of the
remaining pie then the third guest gets
three percent of the remaining pie and
so on until the very last guest gets 100
percent of the rest which guest gets the
largest piece of pie you're not allowed
to use calculators or computers to solve
this problem
I think Vijay in India for suggesting me
this problem and I actually checked it
was in my notes from June of 2017 I'd
seen an article in The Guardian and it
came from the Pythagoras magazine so I
appreciate and know that many of you are
sending me puzzles but please be patient
it can take a long time to make videos
for some of the problems can you figure
this problem out give it a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
a solution so how can we solve this
problem let's start by calculating what
percent of the entire pie each guest
will be getting so the first guest will
get one percent of the entire pie which
is one over 100 of the entire pie now to
calculate the amount that the second
guest gets we're going to need to
calculate the amount of pie remaining
after the first guess this will be 99
out of 100 so the second guest will get
99 out of 100 multiplied by two percent
which is multiplied by 2 over 100 we
then need to calculate the amount of pie
remaining after the second guessed and
that'll be 99 out of 100 multiplied by
98 over 100 and now you can see a
pattern developing
so the third guest will get the
remaining pie from the second guest and
multiply that by 3 out of 100 we can
then continue this pattern so let's
write a general formula for what guessed
K gets this will be the amount of
remaining pie which will be these
actions multiplied together and then we
want to multiply that by K percent which
is K over a hundred we can simplify this
formula as follows and we can further
simplify it because this denominator is
equal to the quantity 100 minus K
factorial so now what can we make out of
this fraction let's consider what would
happen to the next person
guess k plus 1 what fraction of the
entire pie is that person getting we can
solve this by incrementing the index of
K in this formula we now want to compare
these two fractions so let's divide the
top one by the bottom one we can
simplify this by taking the reciprocal
of the terms in the denominator and
multiplying and now we can simplify this
further by cancelling and simplifying
terms notice that 99 factorial cancels
out these two factorials will simplify
to be 100 minus K we then have these two
terms cancelling out to be 1 over 100
and finally we have K plus 1 all over K
so what does this mean let's analyze
this fraction notice the pie slices
increasing in size if and only if this
fraction is larger than 1 so we set up
an inequality that this fraction should
be greater than 1 since all terms are
positive we cross multiply and then we
simplify we end up with the condition
that the pie slice is increasing if and
only if K squared plus K is less than
100 now K is a whole number like 1 2 and
so on and we can see that this
inequality will hold for values of K
going from 1 to 9 if you get 2 K is
equal to 10 it'll be larger than 100 so
at K is equal to 9 we have the fraction
G 10 over G 9 is greater than 1 that
means the size of the slice is
increasing all the way to guess 10 but
then it decreases therefore we have our
answer the largest piece of
the pie goes to guess 10 that's the
answer to this problem now just for fun
we can calculate the share of the entire
pie it'll be this fraction which
simplifies to be this fraction and
that's equal to approximately six point
two eight percent and just as a funny
coincidence this is approximately equal
to two pi divided by 100 it's a pretty
neat problem thanks for watching these
math videos available for free on
YouTube build confidence for students
and inspire mathematical discovery for
viewers around the world they have over
100 million views and the channel has
over 1 million subscribers please
subscribe for free tea up the news
videos and email me a puzzle or math
topic presh and mind your decisions calm
if you so choose you can check out my
merchandise on teespring you can check
out my books listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon thanks for watching and thanks
for your support